let me set this up for you
it's basically gay man straight man
horse your plane that sounds WAY worse
than what it actually is okay let me
rephrase it you know how well that was
unfortunate our and I've maintained this
when people say gay Bueller's bullied
and they'd say if I actually have seen
personally have witnessed gay men get
away with murder especially my wife who
was a model when we'd see just gay
makeup artist rented my fashion
designers the stuff they would say was I
would say well you can say that I'm gay
so the principle here was to test this
hypothesis and so we call this gay horse
because not gay Jared and I went to a
mall he would behave very poorly he
would say something to a woman and then
I would have to say the exact same thing
to another woman as a straight man so we
wanted to compare the reactions a gay
man and a straight man saying the exact
same thing let's see who gets more
leeway guess what I have to say [ __ ]
please multiply I can do that multiple
times as long as didn't have a boyfriend
I can do that you think I could pull off
this color really please no way [ __ ]
please I can do that one I can rock that
come on look at that
yeah I don't think anything's gonna work
for my skin though Oh [ __ ] please
yeah hey do you think so
you're not lying me Oh [ __ ] please
are you serious okay you are just a
nasty [ __ ]
okay you try to get some me off with the
stinky stuff right away it's you're just
nasty nasty [ __ ] look at this wow
that's the first thing you showed me
whoa you are just a nasty little [ __ ]
just a nasty little [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the worst thing I've ever done
in my life I've never felt so bad about
myself because I get my ass kicked I
deserve it
well do you desert I need you to find
the most clear-cut obvious lesbian in
this whole place and tell her you were
just adorable for a lesbian see I would
have thought that'd be harder for you
cuz they don't like gay people lesbians
as kind of was her best friend she gave
me her best dressing arms after I said
it you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
poke around a little more look at this
one in it I just think you are adorable
for a lesbian oh my old friends it just
doesn't fly and you are just accuse a
button thank you
can I just say you are absolutely
adorable for a lesbian those legs that
ass and those shorts are working okay I
can do that
can I just say
that asked miss short it is it isn't
working
thank you I'll tell you spring is in the
air can I just say those legs that asked
those shorts that works
if I were into that we'd be going home
tonight
my shoes black should look at the
pictures of these online perfect perfect
so they gave me some helpful stuff uh
tell you what if I was into that we'd be
going home tonight
well can I just say if I was into that I
would I would totally take you both home
tonight no no I mean if I was into that
I would totally take you home tonight
why is that funny
oh my gosh I'm sure you get this all the
time but your tits are just divine
I have to say that it's a did you
actually say that I actually said that
Shh
you didn't get mad oh is that so is that
the worst nope you didn't have to talk
about how you might take your home in
your truck if people never find her
again I'm not sure that's true at all
hey I ain't sure about which take I'm
sure you get this all the time
your turn I just divine oh stop it you
hear all time can I just say and I'm
sure you get this all the time that your
tits are divine okay what as is I take
you home right today if I swung if I was
playing for the other team but just
think you all know whatever five you I
mean if I could I would just take you
take you home tonight fleet in the back
of my trunk
no one ever find you just puts you my
trunk and just just disappear goodbye
despite gone forever
like permanently gone
[Music]
so what have we learned in studio
cringing he couldn't even watch any time
it took me about 25 minutes to do the
first one right
I could not spit the words out of my
mouth and then as soon as I did I
realized I am invincible I felt like I
could have done anything I want I could
have murdered her on the spot people
would have laughed had a cheery day and
gone on their way so yes sir boy was it
just fun for it was fun it was really
easy I realized I didn't matter what I
said I was their best friend on the flip
side I have never been so embarrassed
doing a video oh I know because I
thought it'd go away when you have a
couple of comments like okay [ __ ]
please and then as Jared got no so bad
I'd have to say this I here's the thing
I know that if any of their husbands or
boyfriends just beat my sorry ass I
would have curled up and taken it yeah
if you like this clip you're like most
of the internet you have a short
attention spin but it was taken from the
full show you can see it in a box
playing next to me that's once a week on
Thursdays full one and a half hour show
or you can join the mug club for the
daily show we have to take some of that
off YouTube because they're monitoring
us and censoring their words